you have this big vision for your life
that you want and on this side your
family gets kidnapped and if you don't
do something they will kill them all
which of those motivates you more right
now in this video when I was 15 16 17 I
was a pretty angry kid I thought that I
had all these issues I would tell people
I have anger issues I'm not a nice
person I would tell people those things
because I believe those things to be
true and I saw them as problems and then
I went to college and in college it's
all propaganda of people who are
teaching who've never actually done work
in a real economy ever they're all
tenured they don't live in reality they
tell everyone they should pursue their
purpose and their passion and the things
that they love and I ate it up and so I
read all these books on pod psychology I
watched all these TED talks and the
problem was I didn't make any progress
and I felt like there was something even
more wrong with me because I didn't feel
any of that stuff I wish I could go back
and tell myself dude
all the stuff they're saying is just not
true
like you don't need any of that you can
embrace the fact that you are angry you
can embrace the fact that you feel like
you are in pain and you can use that to
make the life that you want you don't
have to use the lovey-dovey purpose
passion to build the life that you want
to build what it does is it tells people
that having a negative emotional
experience is a bad thing but half of
your life is below average by definition
and so if you are not using the half of
your life as energy or motivation to
create the life you want then you're at
a huge disadvantage they interviewed the
top Olympic medalists and they found
that they don't actually love winning
they hate losing when they win they
experience relief not Euphoria if you
look at Steve Jobs he wasn't some
happy-go-lucky dude who was like man I
just want to make the world a better
place he was a tough dude to work for
but he created Something Beautiful from
that pain MJ you look at Kobe they had
imaginary situations that they created
in their minds to create more suffering
in their own lives to motivate and uses
fuel imagine you have this big vision
for your life that you want and on this
side your family gets kidnapped and if
you don't do something they will kill
them all which of those motivates you
more right now in this video
probably the one with your family
getting kidnapped it's not trying to
harness a lovey-dovey feeling it's
harnessing pain felt like I had
experienced more pain than I had good I
saw it as a disadvantage I saw it as
something that I had to overcome I
didn't have this big purpose I didn't
have this thing that I loved I didn't
have this thing I was passionate about
and if I could have just skipped all of
that
and started the moment I accepted that
it was okay to be angry what wasn't okay
was not doing anything about it while I
procrastinated by trying to find purpose
jumping from thing to thing to thing
trying to find the thing that really lit
my fire and just accepted that it was
totally okay to work my face off in
disgust from my current circumstance and
who I was then I would have gotten to
where I wanted to go much faster so many
people are believing a lie they have to
be happy they have to have purpose
passion for what they're doing in order
to get out of their situation they think
that they are poor because they don't
have passion that is false you were poor
because you're not doing the activities
that makes you rich and you can fuel
those activities whatever way you damn
well please and so if you are somebody
who is more motivated by the dark side
then Lean Into the Dark Side unlike the
saying the road to hell is paved with
good intentions the equal opposite of
that is the road to Heaven is paved with
bad intentions you can do good [ __ ] with
bad motivation and when I say bad I mean
negative experiences pain anger Etc I
still have tons of motivation from that
side you can use that negative fuel hit
it on speed dial every time you're
confronted with that thing that you
don't want to do you push through it and
what happens you do that enough times
you start to get good at the thing you
start seeing the result of work that has
compounded and start to see a purpose or
start to see a bigger Vision the big
vision for Alex's life until maybe four
years ago was don't be broke what was
your mission with Jim my mission was to
stop being poor there are elements of
[ __ ] that I do that I absolutely love
but there is tons of [ __ ] that I do
every day that I [ __ ] hate I just
don't hate it more than I hate the
alternative and the richest people in
the world they all say it's not about
the money because if it's about the
money you stop the moment you have
enough the people with the wealthiest in
the world have the three things in
common they have the big goal they have
massive fears about never being enough
and then they have impulse control to
stay on goal and oftentimes that impulse
control comes from right as you approach
the guard rail looking over the edge and
imagining what it would be like to have
your friends tell you that you were a
failure have them laugh behind your back
or talk down about you or have your
parents when they're introducing you as
their fun-loving kid you know he's still
figuring himself out that is what would
crush me the boring [ __ ] that you have
to do is not fun Jeff basis talks about
overhead in business there's tons of
things that you have to do and be
willing to do that you do not enjoy the
question is whether you do not enjoy
them more then you do not enjoy the pain
that you are going away from as long as
the pain of moving forward is less than
the pain of going back and the pain that
you imagine from not taking the action
that you know should be taking then you
can use that energy as the single fuel
that you can stay on path for an
extended period of time I'm writing my
book right now I'm on the 11th [ __ ]
draft like there is no feeling that
makes me more sick than the idea that I
could have done more the pain of the
idea of that book not doing well or that
book leading to people being like I
don't think he tried as hard that is the
thing that hurts so much more than going
from the top yet again to make another
video to make an another article to make
another short to make another [ __ ]
chapter revision yet again so that when
I do launch it I think to myself I
literally exhausted every option on this
one of the sayings that I live by is
that I will not do my best I will do
what is required and the difference
between what your best is and what is
required is the difference between what
you think your real best is and what
your actual best is and what your actual
best is is the thing that you would do
to prevent everyone you know from dying
what people care about is the outcome
what you put out in the world now why
you do it what fuels you that's your
business and so if you are in one of
these situations and you can't find that
purpose you can't find that passion cool
but it doesn't give you permission to
not be successful